bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ses
fonctions à ce que nous aurons un réel
impact ont finalement ex plus symbolique
bonsoir ces sanctions ont construit
actuellement aucun impact sur la
politique intérieure en russie et ça de
toute manière les états unis le savent
parfaitement
simplement les états unis utilisent leur
soft pouvoir parce que les sanctions
sont un moyen de pression lance un
message politique non seulement au pays
au classement dressé mais également aux
autres pays en les obligeant se
positionner vous êtes avec nous ou vous
êtes contre nous et c'est en ce sens que
la politique de sanctions systématiques
qui est mise en oeuvre par les états
unis qui en qui emmène en fait l'union
européenne sur cette loi est une
politique de deux combats pour faire
piller la russie d'ailleurs la grande
bretagne à l'onu l'a parfaitement
préciser quand elle a dit que les
relations du monde occidental avec la
russie vont dépendre des décisions
politiques de la russie c'est exactement
ce qu'il dit soit la russie se plie au
diktat occidental à et dans ce cas là
une partie des sanctions pourraient être
allégées mais la paix la russie comme
pays n'existera plus soit la russie
continue à défendre son international et
effectivement nous sommes dans une phase
de confrontation idéologique donc c'est
tout à fait ça alors moscou appelle à
les états unis à ne pas jouer avec le
feu que doit-on comprendre par ces
paroles qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer
la russie a certes l'occupation c'est là
montré jusqu'à présent mais c'est un
pays souvent et qui entend défendre sa
souveraineté politique elle le fait
comprendre la nouvelle administration
maiden
a exprimé par la voix son secrétaire
d'état un changement soit disant en tout
cas annoncées dans le cours politique
américain qui ne voit plus un intérêt à
recourir aux conflits armés long et cher
contre les régimes qu'ils n'estiment pas
démocratique
manifestement ils veulent utiliser la
politique de sanctions dans le cadre de
du retour à la politique antennes man
qui était à l'époque mais en off contre
l'union soviétique la russie évidemment
de son côté ne peut pas laisser faire
c'est une question non seulement de
prestige mais c'est aussi une question
de survie politique parce que plus l'on
montre de signes de faiblesse
puis en face votre adversaire va taper
fort donc effectivement ça ne veut pas
dire que la russie doivent répondre
absolument symétriquement puisque les
intérêts des deux pays sont différents
mais c'était la russie de déterminer
strictement un cours stratégie qui pour
l'instant n'est pas très très clairs et
de montrer aussi quelles sont les
frontières parce que le fait de poser
des frontières en expliquant clairement
quelle sera sa stratégie ça peut avoir
aussi un effet dissuasif ce que pour
l'instant n'est pas extrêmement visible
alors les sanctions occidentales
peuvent-elles dégrader encore davantage
les relations avec la russie comme
semble d'ailleurs lire clairement moscou
on aurait tendance à penser que les
relations sont tellement mauvaise qu'il
soit difficile que cela soit encore pire
mais manifestement les européens et les
américains mettent quand même beaucoup
d'efforts effectivement trouvé un moyen
pour les dégradés de plus en plus donc
oui effectivement il est tout à fait
possible que ce que ces relations se
dégradent encore même si la russie ne
cesse de rêve de répéter que de son côté
elle ne prendra pas l'initiative de la
rupture des relations
il serait quand même intelligent en tout
cas de la part des pays européens qu'il
se souvient de leurs propres intérêts
stratégiques qui est celui d'une
coopération avec la russie ce qui ne
veut pas dire de partager tous les
points de vue mais ce qui veut dire de
maintenir un dialogue constructif ce qui
pour l'instant fait défaut puisque tout
le dialogue entre l'europe et la russie
est entre les mains de l'hymne européen
qui est manifestement tout cas
ouvertement actuellement deux structures
qui défend des intérêts et mantis et non
pas les intérêts européens
au nom de quelle base juridique de quel
texte de quelle institution
ces gouvernements prend-il des sanctions
contre la russie en fait il faut
comprendre que aussi étrangement que
cela puisse paraître les sanctions entre
un pays et un autre pays sont des
mesures qui ressort de la souveraineté
de ce pays c'est à dire que vous avez le
droit d'interdire certaines choses à un
autre pays sur votre territoire puisque
vous êtes maître de votre territoire
dont vous décidez ce qui s'y passe en
revanche là où les sanctions américaines
ou aux belles surtout américaines dans
la logique à vendre à l'encontre de
cette règle tout à fait logique
c'est lorsqu'il condamne deux tiers pays
pour les sanctions que eux prennent à
l'encontre de la russie c'est à dire que
les personnes qui ne sont pas en russie
et qui ne sont pas aux états unis qui ne
respectent pas les sanctions américaines
contre la russie tx porte une
responsabilité devant les états unis
ça c'est une logique impérialiste ce qui
va complètement à l'inversé de la
logique souverainiste merci beaucoup
karina bisch écolo fco professeur invité
à l'université d'état de moscou d'avoir
été avec nous